En tout cas,
c'est une histoire qu'on aurait aimé avoir entendue quand on était plus jeune.
Vu la nature de notre histoire,
je connais les mots qui l'accompagnent automatiquement --
victime, violeur --
les étiquettes aident à organiser les concepts
mais peuvent aussi déshumaniser du fait de leurs connotations.
Quand une personne a été jugée comme victime,
il est facile de la classer comme quelqu'un d'abimé,
de déshonoré,
d'inférieur.
Dès que quelqu'un est catalogué comme violeur,
c'est plus facile de le traiter de monstre --
d'inhumain.
Mais comment allons-nous comprendre ce qui, dans nos sociétés,
produit de la violence
si on refuse de reconnaître l'humanité de ceux qui la commettent ?
Et comment --
(Applaudissements)
Et comment allons-nous autonomiser les survivants
en les traitant d'inférieurs ?
Comment pouvons-nous discuter de solutions à l'une des plus grandes menaces
à la vie de femmes et d'enfants dans le monde entier,
si les mots que nous utilisons font partie du problème ?
TS : De ce que j'ai appris,
mes actes, cette nuit de 1996, étaient égocentriques.
J'ai cru que je méritais le corps de Thordis.
J'ai eu essentiellement de l'influence sociale positive
et des exemples de comportement équitable.
Mais à cette occasion,
j'ai choisi de tirer parti des plus mauvais.
Ceux qui voient les femmes avec peu de valeur intrinsèque
et les hommes avec une affirmation symbolique de leur corps.
Ces influences dont je parle sont externes pour moi.
J'étais seul dans cette chambre à prendre des décisions,
personne d'autre.
Quand vous acceptez quelque chose
et que vous prenez en considération votre culpabilité,
une chose surprenante peut se produire.
J'appelle cela le paradoxe de l'acceptation.
J'ai cru que j'allais céder à cause de la responsabilité.
J'ai cru que mon certificat d'humanité allait être brûlé.
À la place, j'ai pu réellement réaliser ce que j'ai fait
et j'ai compris que cela ne contenait pas entièrement la personne que je suis.
Autrement dit,
vos actes ne doivent pas résumer la personne que vous êtes.
Le bruit dans ma tête a diminué.
L'auto-apitoiement indulgent était privé d'oxygène
et a été remplacé par l'air pur de l'acceptation --
l'acceptation que j'ai fait du mal à cette merveilleuse personne juste là ;
l'acceptation que je fais partie d'un groupe d'hommes
qui ont été sexuellement violents envers leur partenaire.
Ne sous-estimez pas la puissance des mots.
Dire à Thordis que je l'ai violée a changé mon entente avec moi-même
autant qu'avec elle.
Mais surtout,
la faute s'est déplacée de Thordis vers moi.
Bien trop souvent,
la responsabilité est attribuée à la survivante de violences sexuelles
et pas à l'homme qui les a commises.
Bien trop souvent,
le déni et la fuite laissent les deux partis très loin de la vérité.
Il y a une conversation publique en cours en ce moment
et comme beaucoup de gens,
nous sommes heureux qu'il y ait moins de recul
face à cette discussion difficile mais importante.
Et c'est une grande responsabilité de nous joindre à cela.
TE : Ce que nous avons fait n'est pas un traitement qu'on prescrit aux autres.
Personne n'a le droit de dire à quiconque comment gérer sa douleur la plus profonde
ou sa plus grande erreur.
Briser le silence n'est jamais chose facile
et, en fonction d'où vous êtes dans le monde,
ça peut être dangereux de parler de viol.
Je réalise que même l'événement le plus traumatisant dans ma vie
est toujours un témoignage de mes privilèges,
parce que je peux en parler sans être ostracisée
ou tuée.
Mais avec ce privilège de pouvoir m'exprimer
découle la responsabilité de l'utiliser.
C'est le minimum que je dois
aux autres survivants qui ne peuvent pas s'exprimer.
L'histoire que nous venons de révéler est unique,
mais pourtant si commune car la violence sexuelle est une épidémie mondiale.
Cela n'a pas à être ainsi.
L'une des choses utiles sur mon chemin vers la guérison
est de m'instruire sur les violences sexuelles.
En conséquence, je lis, j'écris
et je parle de ce problème depuis plus de dix ans,
je vais à des conférences à travers le monde.
Selon mon expérience,
les participants à ces événements sont presque exclusivement des femmes.
Mais il est temps qu'on arrête de traiter la violence sexuelle
comme un problème de femmes.
(Applaudissements)
Une majorité des violences envers les femmes et les hommes
est commise par des hommes.
Pourtant, leurs voix sont cruellement sous-représentées dans cette discussion.
Mais nous sommes tous nécessaires ici.
Imaginez simplement la souffrance que l'on peut soulager
si on osait confronter ce problème tous ensemble.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)